[Music]
with all the work to do people to see
traffic jams to get stuck in we all
sometimes wish we could be in two places
at once
we've already cloned sheep cows even
monkeys what if we cloned ourselves
would clone have feelings and be
self-conscious
could you genetically modify them to
become better than yourself this is what
if and here's what would happen if you
cloned your body cloning is reproducing
a genetically identical copy of an
organism scientists are doing that all
the time but they aren't cloning humans
they're mostly making copies of cells or
DNA fragments for research purposes
occasionally they'll clone an animal too
in the case of Dolly the sheep
scientists took a somatic cell from an
adult sheep and inserted it into an egg
that had all of its DNA information
removed since then we've cloned dogs
cats horses and just recently primates
it looks like researchers have figured
this cloning thing out what if one day
they decided to start cloning humans it
turns out some organisms are harder to
genetically duplicate than others
dogs are harder to clone than cats and
rats are even harder to clone than dogs
humans are also among the toughest tough
but possible what if you were the first
one ever to make a clone of yourself
would it be an exact copy of you I hate
to break it to you but not only would
your clone have a different personality
but they'd also look different think
about it this way just how identical are
identical twins you may not notice at
first glance but when you look closer
one of them has a birthmark on their
cheek and the other one is a little
taller while you won't notice much of a
difference in a sheep clone once you
looked at your fresh from the lab you
you'd see that it's well not you you're
more than just a product of your genetic
code your character behavior even your
appearance depend on the environment in
which you were raised you can make a
copy of your genes but copying your
memories and experiences is impossible
oh and you realize that your clone
wouldn't be your grown-up self right
you'd have to raise that cloned baby
before they got to your age if the
ever do because clones are typically
very unhealthy most likely they'd have a
defective heart liver and brain as well
as a very weak immune system many cloned
animals had their cells aged much faster
than normal
your clones body would probably get old
and deteriorate much sooner than you
unfortunately your clone would be very
sick and died early and they may not
even look like you not to mention a
totally different personality human
cloning is illegal almost everywhere on
earth now and then a group of
researchers will claim to have cloned a
human successfully but with no
scientific information to prove their
claims human cloning remains in the
realm of science fiction so if you're
ever on a trip abroad and meet someone
who looks like you don't panic the
chances that you were cloned are close
to zero have you seen your look-alike
what if everyone in the world had a
double well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you